so when we talk about how amazing it is
to have people who still support Donald
Trump one group in particular that still
manages to surprise me even though I
admit that they should not would be
evangelical voters they still surprise
me because out of all of the people who
should be able to see how disgusting of
a human being Donald Trump is
evangelical support Donald Trump in an
amazing fashion and I tried to figure
out and understand why but it's a very
simplistic lens it really doesn't
require so it's a simplistic phenomenon
rather that doesn't really require much
analysis so long as you number one
oppose abortion or ostensibly oppose
abortion because really what's the
over-under on the number of abortions
Donald Trump is paid for but I digress
so long as you outwardly oppose abortion
and so long as you outwardly oppose
same-sex marriage then you still get the
support of the evangelical base case in
point there's an amazing article in The
New Yorker that was a long format
interview between Steve Bannon and the
and the journalists and Steve ban and
begin to divulge to America essentially
how Donald Trump thinks and treats
thinks of and treats Mike Pence and so
in that article they discuss how anytime
someone comes out of Mike Pence's office
keep jokes and mocks Mike Pence saying
did he make you pray and then the other
thing that was when the conversation
were went to overturning Roe vs. Wade
they had a legal scholar there who said
that even if Donald Trump was able to
put another justice on the Supreme Court
who would overturn Roe versus Wade that
the state's on a state-by-state level
that they very likely will pass or make
abortion legal in the individual states
and so Donald Trump used that as an
opportunity to turn to Mike Pence to say
see all this energy that you put into
this and you're gonna fail anyway last
but not least when the conversation
turned to the LGBTQ community Donald
Trump abruptly said don't ask Mike Pence
about that because he just wants to hang
all the gays now
notwithstanding the vulgarity and the
ridiculousness of the President of the
United States joking about religious
fundamentalism so extreme that they
would kill people because of their
sexuality we'll set that aside for a
moment this just shows you the amount of
disdain that Donald Trump genuinely has
for religious people now I'm not
defending the religious people in this
conversation because I think their
ideology and their political positions
and a lot of their religious rhetoric
should be condemned and I'm a Christian
so I just outright tell you my pitch
should be mocked and mocked on a regular
basis everyone in attendance at the
Values Voters summit should be mocked
and mocked on an ongoing basis because
what they stand for and what they
represent is an Anatomy to people who
simply want to coexist and live their
life the way they see fit without having
to conform to someone else's religious
expectations but if you notice I pointed
out the values voter summit attendees
but Donald Trump himself was just there
last week speaking to the Values Voter
Summit and pandering to that same exact
group of people so the question is how
could evangelicals still support him
when they know Oh in every way
imaginable Donald Trump is not anything
remotely like what they want people to
be right everything they try to force
other people to be sexual purity and all
these other types then Donald Trump is
the exact opposite of it humility
Donald Trump is not humble patience
Donald Trump does have me patient Donald
Trump does not demonstrate anything that
would remotely make you think that he
was a Christian at all whatsoever but
now they actually have evidence of
Donald Trump mocking their very
positions but what is happening they
still support Donald Trump that's
because they don't really care all they
want is someone in the White House
actually strike that let me take it back
they don't care because they have they
have long since abandoned their core
issues right even if we think that they
are wrong on their core issues which I
do believe that they're wrong on their
core issues they have morphed away from
anything concerning religion anything
concerning morality and they their long
they have long since abandoned that and
many of these evangelical leaders if you
take Jerry Falwell Jr for example he is
he said last week that Donald Trump is
going to be the greatest president since
Richard Nixon I mean I'm sorry well
that's probably the true statement but
what he actually said is that Donald
Trump is going to be the greatest
president since Abraham Lincoln and this
is a this is a man who's the the head of
one of the largest Christian
universities in the country probably in
the world so this is this is this
demonstrates to us how they have
abandoned their own core principles
which we disagree with their core
principles but they've abandoned it in
exchange for political power in the
Republican Party it is 100 percent about
political power in the Republican Party
they don't care about their own their
own pro-choice or pro-life positions if
they did they would oppose Donald Trump
they don't really care about opposition
to same-sex marriage because if they did
they have to oppose Trump because he
clearly is not on the same side as them
so all it has boiled down to at this
point is maintaining political power in
the Republican Party no matter what even
if that means them betraying their
values that I would agree and argue are
not values to begin with but this is a
Republican Party this is the evangelical
right as it exists right now and when we
look at that group of core people that
38 percent as we showed you in polling
38 percent of people who still support
Donald Trump a lot of them are
evangelicals because despite everything
to the contrary everything all the
evidence that says otherwise they still
believe that Donald Trump is somehow set
by God to save America never mind the
fact I never mind the fact that Donald
Trump is a clear and present threat to
the United States of America but beside
because of all of his policies because
of his office Nastase Donald Trump is
the complete antithesis of what a good
god-fearing Americans should be
according to evangelicals so that just
shows you the depth and the depravity
and the lack of substance that exists in
this particular group of people and and
and particularly in them I want to make
a distinct
here the leadership people like Jerry
Falwell Jr Paul of white Robert Jeffress
Tony Perkins of the Family Research
Council all those people they are
completely bereft of any sense of
dignity and any sense of morality that
they try to force you to have they don't
really care about that the leadership
all they know how to do and all they are
concerned with is using their pulpits
and their platforms to usher their
congregations to vote for the Republican
Party in exchange or political power hey
guys thanks so much for hanging out with
me for this hour David will be back
broadcasting remotely and if you are a
member get ready for the bonus show we
will see you on the bonus show take care